all right let's see what we got here
um
let's go to the beginning
that's not the beginning
okay this is the beginning here sharing
this publicly now because keeping it to
myself was causing more damage to my
mental health than sharing it ever could
do a year later
all right so plain and simple so this
looks like this is Jonah Hill texting he
says if you need surfing with men
boundaryless and appropriate friendships
with men to model to post pictures of
yourself in a bathing suit to post
sexual pictures friendships with women
who are who in an unstable place and
from your wild recent past Beyond
getting a lunch or coffee or something
respectful I'm not the right partner for
you these things bring you to a place of
happiness I support it and there will be
no hard feelings these are my boundaries
for a remote for a romantic partnership
first of all partnership is the dumbest
word used by guys today like
tell me you're a beta male without
telling me you're a beta male when you
say partnership men and women aren't
Partners okay we're men and we're women
there's husbands there's wives there's
boyfriends there's girlfriend knock it
off with a partnership stuff it sounds
stupid okay makes you sound like a wimp
my boundaries with you based on the ways
these actions have hurt our trust I
don't really see that much wrong here
with what he's saying
um if you're in a long-term relationship
with a chick and you want to protect or
preserve the Integrity of the
relationship
you kind of have the expectation that
she's not going to put the relationship
at risk like hanging out with other
dudes it's one of the red flags in my
book is women that keep dudes around
from their past and if she's keeping
guys around from her past I didn't see
it on on Instagram so I don't know if
she deleted the pictures or took them
out or maybe it was remote or extremely
random
um so it doesn't really seem like that
much that much of a problem from that
perspective but if she was doing it
there's nothing wrong with saying hey I
have this boundary and I don't date
women that hang out with guys from her
past
um that's fine and if she wants to hang
out with guys from her past and let her
go it's completely all right there's
nothing wrong with that
um he says boundaryless inappropriate
friendships with men without much frame
around that
inappropriate Define it you know
um
don't know what it is to model
is she a model I don't know I mean look
if she was a model before they met and
modeling as part of her life and part of
her career you kind of have to expect
her to keep doing that right so that
seems somewhat bizarre post pictures
yourself in a bathing suit well if
you're surfing
and you're in warm water you're probably
going to wear a bathing suit unless it's
cold water then you put on something to
you know keep you warm like a wetsuit or
a dry suit or whatever is necessary
um so I mean look if she was a surfer
before she's going to be a surfer after
you kind of expect none of that to
change to post sexual pictures I didn't
see any sexual pictures I just saw
lifestyle sort of pictures like she's
walking away she's on the surfboard
she's sitting with her friend laughing
and talking blah blah blah uh
friendships with women who are unstable
so if she's got like loser friends maybe
that's what he's trying to say like you
know she's got some weird friends that
are inappropriate or do inappropriate
things then at the end of all that he's
saying I'm just not the right partner
for you if that's what you want to do
then I support it and that's cool that
to me seems reasonable now what he's
holding is unreasonable I don't know
because there's no frame around it maybe
it was maybe it wasn't some of it seems
okay some of it seems like maybe it
wasn't but I think overall if you're
dealing with a chick that's doing that
and she comes at you and she's like Hey
You Know Rich where do we stand I dig
your Vibe I don't want to share you I
want to be in a relationship with you
kind of be your girl friend then that's
when you're in a position to say that's
fine but
um my preference is not to date a gal
that's posting provocative pictures of
her in a bathing suit is this something
that's going to continue right or are
you looking for something long-term you
know maybe Joan is old enough he wants
to have kids I don't know it seems like
it because he just had a kid with this
woman that he moved on to so maybe that
was his his schtick right and she wasn't
into it but her whole thing over here at
the top says effort see the the misuse
of boundaries this is where he started
to get called misogynistic controlling
uh unbelievable this man sent like
this looks like it's him messaging her
uh hearty eyes how you doing she writes
he says good I want to see you I don't
see anything wrong with that he's
sliding into her DM saying hey like this
picture can I see you
would then be upset I didn't read his
mind and take down pics that I was once
in a relationship with him holy hell
this is hypocritical he is a bat
dude yep don't know who she's talking to
there Gaslight much uh even the person I
loved and shared my bed with uses me and
can't just be like yeah you were super
nice it hurts so badly but I'm done
apologizing I was so lovely to you I
don't know who wrote that to who
she being our couple's therapist at the
time dude what do you need a couple's
therapist for if you're dating a girl
for a year if you need a couple's
therapists because you're dating for a
year don't be in that relationship
relationships shouldn't be hard they
shouldn't be difficult they should be
easy and flow this this notion that you
have to be in couples therapy like you
should be in the honeymoon phase for the
first year should be all rainbows and
butterflies for the most part I don't
know why people like this is the first
sign that you're wasting your time with
a shitty relationship that you have to
go to therapy within the first year
that
she had me agree to paddle away from my
any man that approached me on the water
no matter his age I was instructed to
say I'm going to go and talk to my
boyfriend and then paddle away so this
is I guess her that makes me want to go
stab someone wow who's a therapist what
she was like enabling his possessive
isolation wow wow wow I don't know who
this is writing back and forth maybe
that's a therapist I don't know it
wouldn't yes
licensed professional she instructed to
come up with a safe word when Jonah was
young she instructed us to come up with
a safe word for when Jonah was yelling
at me that some it was pineapple
so she's talking to a friend of hers
there it seems why why is she releasing
this like what is the benefit to
[Music]
like is is Jonah Hill being nominated
for an Oscar or something has he been me
too I don't understand why this would
come out a year later like you part ways
you move on just you know go on
with your life right
Jonah I'm so sorry okay is this Jonas
saying this I'm sorry I said that icky
to see how I took blame for him I'm
sorry I said that I had a couple of
beers and I'm just upset feeling that we
can go that we can't do surf social
things without an uncomfortable
situation arising that usually feels
like my fault somehow I feel you pull
away and then feeling of being defective
Creeps in I think I'm not socially
intelligent enough to meet your needs as
a partner as a partner there it is again
and then I get frustrated and angry at
myself and just want to rip the Band-Aid
off I'm not good enough for you well it
would be a lot easier to understand
who's speaking to who instead of saying
being a partner like being your
girlfriend or being your boyfriend
this is this is why this stuff over here
can get misunderstood very easily with
the whole partner in moments of
conflict my brain thinks you want to
dump me because I'm not good enough for
you and you're the greatest of all time
and you can do better and you will
immediately once you end things with me
you're right we can't do surf social
things or develop trust until you
consider me and make decisions that give
regard to our
cut off after that you don't even get
the rest of it I'm not really sure how
you're supposed to form
a opinion on the facts if the facts keep
getting left out or
cut out I don't know if it's intentional
or not
surface think I love how your therapist
thinks I suck I lit I literally am the
best boyfriend on Earth
your therapist number one boyfriend I
don't care for your misogyny
okay so this is him on the left with the
gray obviously in this case uh you're
right we can't do social things of Vel
trust okay so this is a continuation on
the one from two slides ago I've been
vulnerable as possible and I am telling
you I'm needing you to step up to the
plate which you can I'm sure of it but
these losers don't get your time if you
want me straight up it's consideration I
suspect Your Love of Surfing but I
respect myself as well and your love is
surfing and being in those situations
and lack of awareness not mutually
exclusive this isn't me I have my own
issues if you want okay so now he's
talking marriage and family if you want
marriage and family you can't use the 25
cards step up and cut these people
don't get your time or your kindness at
the sacrifice of mine okay so clearly
they're having a conversation about
something long-term whether that's
living together whether that's raising a
family they're starting to have
conversations about marriage and family
and it sounds like to me he's basically
saying at this point by these people he
met any friend of mine that he hadn't
personally approved of yeah thank you
is that is that really a misogynist is
that really controlling if a guy says to
a gal hey
you want to have a family you want to be
with me cool that's awesome let's go do
it but there's some people out there
that are detrimental to our relationship
it's called setting healthy boundaries
like if a gal goes out partying and
going to nightclubs and she's also
talking about having kids and a family
and she wants to go out with her
girlfriends every weekend twice a week
or something like that partying to the
late hours a night she comes home passed
out drunk half the time then that's it
it's entirely reasonable for a dude to
say look you know if you're serious
about this as a relationship I don't
date women that party I don't date women
that get you know pissed drunk every
night and go out multiple times a week
on an ongoing basis that's that's not
what I do have fun right and then just
kind of like bless and release let her
go sort of thing
that makes me feel like you're testing
me to see if you should keep me around
or dump me because there's something
wrong with me I'm a nerdy dorky unaware
naive idiot socially I hear you these
are your words not mine they're going
back and forth this is a warning to all
girls if your partner is talking to you
like this make an Exit Plan love you all
call me if you need an ear good ears
I made my boundaries clear for your
loose let go some of them you've made it
clear and I hope it makes you happy
respect whoever you want to live your
life sort of done with explaining myself
okay because we're all three removed
okay so this is her removing things off
social media it seems three removed not
the video yet
it is my best surfing video would you
feel better if the cover frame was
different any more specific ones that
bother you yes one that isn't of your
ass in a thong
it's not a thong but K as far as other
pictures you are in a bathing suit
surfing or not not a thong but okay I'm
done there's tons I'm just going back in
the past month
I mean
dude she was a surfer when you met her
did you think she was gonna stop surfing
when you got with her right like unless
she said you know I want to give this up
and start popping out babies and you
know be your wife sort of thing you know
it's clear that there was a misalignment
in where they were going you know with
this relationship sort of thing
he wanted family it seems and she wanted
to surf
so how is that controlling just
part ways
I'm just over explaining myself
screenshots of surf picks on my insta
feed it looks like a stack of picks that
I don't know if she blurred them out or
whatever it's just constant it doesn't
reflect where we're at or where you say
you want to be I respect your skill and
you're surfing I respect how you want to
present yourself
I just want it's just constant it
doesn't reflect where we're at okay
surfing I respect that you're hot and
beautiful I respect however that you
want to live but I also respect myself
and what I'm interested in my own life
and what I let my heart blah blah blah
like dude is just going on and on like
from from the guy's perspective this
looks weak it's just him talking
talking talking talking and she's not
responding to any of this she probably
put her phone down or shut down
the app because she doesn't want to deal
with it
that's weak dude
it's state your point if she respects
the boundary and she wants to be a part
of it cool if not cool move on it's all
right you're not a good fit
it's not misogyny it's not hate it's not
Auntie whatever it's it's like you're
not a good fit that's it
surfing with men so this is the other
thing over here that we've already seen
take some count billion operative
respect that simple because I'm tired of
your attitude towards surf culture and
contests that place because I deserve no
she's a hippie too right I mean like you
can tell by her freaking feed that she's
got this nonchalant hippie sort of
Lifestyle you know Vibe tour that's what
she like you're not going to turn her
into a square you know
been more than patient the still
here F that contest F that place F not
respected me always in every situation
within surf culture or you don't get it
and don't don't get me it's hurtful and
unacceptable to me get it I don't know
if you get it or care or give a
about that more than after Dr Stern
Dr Stern is a couple's therapist we were
seeing once a week for about four
months
my God I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out